european houston this is station i'm
ready for the event
european space agency this is mission
control houston please call station for
a voice check
station this is the open space agency
how do you hear me
station this is the european space
agency how do you hear me
hello joseph i read you loud and clear
how me
hello matthias uh very nice to see you
and very nice to be with you
i'm today in brussels and i have the
honor of being with the president of the
european commission this is jose van der
lion mrs ozil of underlying we'll have a
chat with young people and as you know
inspiring young people is extremely
important because they are the talents
of the future and we need their energy
and their inspiration
so today i'm also
joined by a moderator gaspar and let me
hand over to gaspar for the moderation
of this talk
good afternoon thank you all for being
with us today i am here in brussels with
the president of the european commission
ursula van der leyen and we are
connected live with esa astronaut
matthias morar on the international
space station we have received many
questions for matthias on social media
but why don't we start with you
president vanderlaan thank you very much
gaspar
and it's good to see you again first
we've seen each other in strasbourg and
now in brussels
and thank you also to director general
joseph ashbach and of course to the
european space agency for this great
opportunity
and last but not least thank you
matthias for taking the time to chat
with us so matias do you hear us loud
and clear
and hello everyone listening to us yes i
read you're loud and clear how me
that's very good we hear you're also
loud and clear we're impressed the many
languages you're speaking but yes
mathias as you know uh the european
union's top priority is to become the
first climate neutral continent by 2050.
we want to protect our precious natural
resources our forests and our oceans
and this is why we have the european
green deal it's basically our road map
to save the planet
but it's not always easy for us here on
earth to grasp how fast the planet is
changing
and therefore to convince everybody how
fast we have to act
climate change is a really urgent matter
so i was always wondering how that
change is visible from space
and matthias
what kind of changes can you actually
see on your
on our planet with your own eyes or
maybe through stereoscope perhaps you
might want to tell us about it
yes indeed we from the international
space station we fly at a height of
around 400 kilometers above our planet
and 16 times a day we circle around our
planet and we can observe a lot of
details we can see slash and burn forest
we can see droughts so lakes that used
to be on old maps we cannot see any more
here
glaciers that used to be much bigger on
old maps or older astronauts tell us
about
they are now smaller and
we can also see that human mining takes
a uh puts a lot of scars into the
surface of our planet
and
so we can observe a lot of these
floodings for example that i observed
two or three weeks ago in brazil
or other events like the eruption of
volcanoes we see quite a lot of stuff
from the space station
and we can report about it we are
eyewitnesses of all this
but i believe the best data to observe
our planet and to deliver also the in
like the important data that politicians
need to act um comes from the european
copernicus earth observation fleet and
these satellites produce a lot of data
they are actually the best earth
observation satellite fleet that exists
currently in space around our planet
earth europe is leading here and this
data has free data access policy
and so it's very good for european
economy and also for startups to use
this data
you seem very committed to climate
action matthias was it always a cause
close to your heart
you know it's like now i circle our
planet in 90 minutes and
i actually did one around the world trip
before becoming an astronaut and i had
the chance to travel many many countries
of this planet and i've been in india
when there was flooding i've been in
indonesia when there were landslides so
i've seen how like people suffer from
very close up once nature hits and like
destroys the baseline of their life i've
been
also on pacific beautiful islands but
islands that are so close to the water
and now with the rising sea level like
these paradises are threatened to
disappear and so it's like the entire
life that people lived on this island
has no substance anymore so i
i've seen quite a lot of places and i
think that changed my attitude and it
made me really to become an ambassador
for our planet earth and to protect the
climate and to reduce the warming of our
planet
indeed and i hope many will hear your
important message today uh one last
question from me before i give the floor
to our audience uh why is your mission
called cosmic kiss it's very intriguing
to me
yes cosmic kiss is the name of my
mission and basically it expresses a
love that we have for space ever since
people looked into the night sky they
wondered what is out there and
how did life come to earth and how did
the universe
start up with and how was our solar
system formed and is there another
planet earth where life is possible so
all these are very interesting questions
and um so the my mission patch is
inspired by a really old depiction of
the night sky it's the skydesk of nebra
that is a relic that was created 4 000
years ago it was found like less than 20
years ago in germany
and
i was inspired by this skydisk and
thought like this is a very nice
expression to animate people and to
motivate people to be interested in
space and uh yeah i forgot to mention
also before it's like my patch for my
mission but i think a really important
patch is also the european patch against
climate change
wow
thank you very much matthias
and now i will give the floor to our
community we have a first question from
aisha
hello matias and everybody my name is
aisha and i live in france
it is always fascinating to follow the
adventure of the astronauts on board the
iss but also the incredible work of the
european space agency is doing to
unravel the mysteries of the universe
i would like to know if there is a
solution so that we can get rid of the
space debris that treated the iss and if
so how
thank you over
but yes
this one's for you
but yes
this one's for you
okay
okay so it's like the message came a
little bit un distorted up here it's
space debris that's what i understood
exactly exactly
so perhaps matthias it is in indeed
space debris
and this is an issue
it is indeed space debris
and this is an issue
please go ahead mrs preston
matthias this one's for you about the
debris
okay i take this question and actually
it's a very very very up-to-date topic
because even today we have a collision
warning for later on today with space
debris so
currently our planning teams on the
ground are calculating if this debris
has actually um like the potential to
hit with us around nine half past nine
o'clock tonight and if so then we need
to do a debris avoidance maneuver so we
need to accelerate the iss and to avoid
this debris and this happened already
two weeks ago when we had to avoid
debris
and it two weeks ago it was even more
challenging because we had to avoid one
but by avoiding one we had the next
debris upcoming so the the scientists
and the technicians on the ground they
had to calculate a perfect acceleration
of the iss to dodge in between the two
debris particles or parts and that shows
us that there is a lot of debris here in
space and it's a it's a very important
topic um
not only for the iss because it puts us
at risk but also because of the all the
satellites that we have um imagine a
life without satellites i think you
would be really surprised how life would
change it's like all the data that we
get from our satellites from weather to
like gps or navigation systems like
galileo earth observation satellites
like copernicus so i think modern
society couldn't work
without any satellite data so we need to
take action we need to um
like make sure that we avoid
future space debris and ether has here a
declaration and josef ashbach declared
it very strongly
we by 2030 want to have a net
contribution to space debris which means
like we need to take actions to take
massive parts out of space
but also reduce the introduction of new
space particles
another topic is also important that we
get a space traffic management today we
have air traffic management when one
plane within europe flies from one
country to the other or outside of
europe we have clear rules and and we
have people that check these rules for
space um we don't have such clear and
strong rules and the political action is
required and i think europe should lead
this and take a strong role into this
one
well indeed matthias this is uh
fascinating to listen to you because
it's actually the the fact that huge
increase of number of satellites in
space
and as you set the greater the number of
satellites uh the more the risk that has
um that is out there so indeed this is
why in two weeks we will present at the
european level a strategy for space
traffic management just as you described
so we will look at every topic first of
course as you said the need for new
common rules in space
and then
we have to ensure an efficient
management of space traffic as we have
the air traffic or the road traffic
rules and most importantly of course we
have to convince our partners in the
world that we need to tackle this issue
together so
as you see space will keep us busy
thank you president now we have a
question from freyja
is it lonely in space
or how is it up there
or how is it up there
it's a very nice question indeed there
are not so many people in space and
space is huge so um you could think that
we feel lonely here in space currently
there are only two space stations
circling our planet earth one is the
international space station and we are
currently seven astronauts here on board
but we always work together
we also spend like a lot of time outside
of work together so we don't feel lonely
and we can call our families there's
also another space station flying along
our planet is the chinese space station
and there are three
chinese colleagues of us which i
personally know from
from a joint training with them
and
i also don't think that they feel
lonely thank you now we have a question
from kian
hello
my name is kian i want to ask you a
question
that question is
could you see
well we fly 400 kilometers above our
planet earth and a lot of satellites fly
much much higher than us and some of
them fly around our level and the
satellites usually move very fast and so
it's like i can see them in the same way
that you can see them on the ground
whenever
the satellites
have their solar panels that's the way
they get their energy from when these
solar panels are hit by the sun and i
get the sun reflection then i can see
them for a brief moment so i see them
very quickly moving on the horizon but
that's also when you look in the night
sky and you see very quickly moving uh
small points that's also a sun
reflection from the satellite so it's
very similar
that must be very impressive uh now we
have a question from tala and i'm sure
all the young people watching us will
enjoy this one
hi my name is tala aburuzu and my
question for you is what is the advice
you would give for future aspiring
astronauts
well if you want to be astronaut then i
would say like follow your heart follow
your dream
it's um very easy to be an astronaut i
have to say like being here in space i
can float and i can do whatever i like
to do it's like i love all the science
work that we do and the technician work
and the repair works that we do
the difficult part is to become an
astronaut
and so a lot of people have the same
dream so you need to be good in school
you need to be good in university and
so it's very important that you are a
good pupil but especially that you do
what you like and what you love to do
it's uh if you don't
like your work that you do then i think
it's really really difficult to come up
here yeah but the most important part is
follow your dreams follow your heart
makes me want to become an astronaut
myself thank you matthias our last
question comes from kami
hi
i'm very glad to have a woman as
president of the european class mission
but i'm wondering why not we have more
women astronauts what can we do to get
more women in space
thank you
again a very good question actually
before we give the floor to matthias
president do you want to say anything
about this
well indeed we should definitely have
more women in space and more women on
earth in science technology and
engineering
but the most important thing is for
girls and women to understand that no
job is out of reach
and as you've said matthias
live your dreams go by your heart
believe in yourselves and yes of course
girls and women can go to space this is
my message
yes
and i couldn't say it any better than
mrs president i can only agree with you
um indeed it's like i have one colleague
up here in space kayla baron she's
another astronaut and she is like a
wonderful astronaut and she does a lot
of the stuff like better than us guys so
it's like um yeah so the girls should
dare to be an astronaut that girls
should also dare to have lead positions
very often it's not that they cannot do
it but they just believe they are not as
good as the boys and so um yeah but i
can reassure um i've seen many female
astronauts and when i fly back in april
my european colleague samantha crystal
ferretti from italy
will come up here and she will continue
my work
and she's already been up here in space
for like more than half a year and she's
just an outstanding astronaut and on her
spacecraft there will be two female
astronauts and two male astronauts so
it's like 50 50 and i think that should
be the future a mixed team is always
much better than a single male or a
single woman team i would say
in the european astronaut selection that
we have currently ongoing um we are
entering round two of the selection
process and i'm very happy to hear that
uh joseph ashbach announced a few days
ago that 40
of the participants that entered now
round two are female astronaut
candidates thank you matt yes
unfortunately we are it's already time
to say goodbye thank you all for being
with us today
and thank you president van der leyen
and matthias moro from iss
it has been a true pleasure to host this
unique interview with you i hope you
enjoyed it as much as we did president
yes thank you so much matthias for
making us travel with you to space and
thank you for reminding us how beautiful
our planet is we must do everything
possible to protect it so that the next
generation of men and women astronauts
can enjoy the same side as you do and we
wave goodbye
now thank you also for my my side
mathias this was such a pleasure the
space chat uh and having a president
jose van der lion with us having young
kids uh with us uh asking their
questions it was just fascinating and uh
really thank you i thank also nasa uh
for helping us doing the logistics of
making this possible houston thank you
and uh once more gaspar has been a
fantastic moderator and once more
russell won the lion it was such a
pleasure thank you for my side and
goodbye